Okay. Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Isa Akın. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistenz-Detente. Ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch
durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Markus.
Nachname?
Hans.
Herr Hans. Richtig?
Richtig.
Okay. Herr Hans. Was für eine Summe? Was kann ich wir zutun?
Also ich habe seit der Nacht habe ich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie starke Bauchschmerzen?
Seit der Nacht.
Nacht.
Ich habe nicht genau diese Schmerzen erklärt. Herr Hans ist ja drückend oder...
Ich habe mir so stechende Schmerzen im Unterbauch.
Unterbauch.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Im Leiste.
Leiste.
Welche Seite?
Links.
Linke Seite.
Herr Hans.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden? Haben Sie erbrochen oder ist Ihnen über?
Ja, ich habe starke Übelkeit. Erbrochen habe ich noch nicht.
Übelkeit.
Sind die Schmerzen zum ersten Mal oder haben Sie solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ich habe diese Schmerzen noch nie gehabt.
Noch nie gehabt.
Okay, ist das zum ersten Mal.
Haben Sie auch Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Ich habe leichte Verstopfung. Durchfall habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 1?
Um Schmerzen und sehr starken Schmerzen.
Was würden Sie einordnen?
Um 6 bis 7.
7.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Hans?
Nein, die Schmerzen sind das Einzige, was ich habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Fieber oder Stelfrost?
Ja, ich habe gestern gemessen. Ich habe ungefähr 39 Grad gehabt.
39 Grad? Okay.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß oder nicht?
Ich habe die Nacht nicht gespürt. Nein.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Auch nicht.
Okay.
Und so, haben Sie etwas gegen Schmerzen eingenommen?
Ich habe die Nacht ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ibuprofen? Einmal oder?
Ja, zweimal.
Wie meint Sie?
Wie Dosisierung?
Ach so, die normalen 400 Milligramm.
400.
Das hat geholfen?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Nein.
Deswegen habe ich auch zwei Stück genommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden oder
Herr Hans, oder möchten Sie etwas Hünsefügen über ihre Beschwerden?
Nein, ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Was denken Sie, was es ist?
Können Sie mir etwas gegen Schmerzen geben?
Okay.
Herr Hans, haben Sie Schmerzen oder bekommen Sie sehr gut Luft?
Mit der Luft habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich habe nur Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Husten?
Nein.
Ich habe die Unterbauchschmerzen.
Unterbauchschmerzen.
Können Sie etwas gegen Schmerzen geben?
Ja, ich kann Sie eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen bis zum Aufnahmegensprach aushalten?
Ich versuche.
Okay.
Herr Hans, schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, nicht.
Nein, wegen der Schmerzen?
Richtig.
Herr Hans, haben Sie im Laufe derzeit in sechs Monaten
ab oder zu genügend wie ist ihr Apetit?
Gut.
Gut, kein Problem.
Okay.
Ich möchte über ihre Medizinischefolge schicken.
Ich möchte über Ihre Medizinischefolge schicken.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ich wurde 10 Jahre lang kniooperiert.
Ja, ich habe 10 Jahre lang kniooperiert.
Wo ist Ihr Seite?
Links.
Warum wurden Sie operiert?
Erschleißen.
Okay.
Lassen Sie uns mir Ihre Medikamente, Herr Hans,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein gegen Bluthochdruck
oder bei Bedarf eine Medikamente?
Ja, ein gegen Bluthochdruck, ein, seit drei Monaten.
Ich nehme Amnodipin ein.
Wie viele?
Amnodipin.
Einmal tätig.
Wie viel Dosierung wissen Sie?
5 Milligramm.
Herr Hans, ich möchte über Ihre Gewohnheit sprechen.
Wenn das nicht ist ordentlich für Sie, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ein, zwei Gläserweine in der Woche.
Okay, mit der Nämen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder eine andere Substanz?
Oder haben Sie einen Problem?
Nein.
Herr Hans, sind Ihnen eine bestimmte Allergie oder unverträglich bekannt?
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, Herr Hans?
Verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Was machen Sie von Beruf?
Brokaufmann.
Wo leben Sie Ihre Frau nicht zusammen?
Ja, ich bin Bayern.
Und ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familien stellen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch, Herr Hans?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, meine Herzin fragt.
Und Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ist aktuell 85 Jahre alt.
85 Jahre alt.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie hat ein paar kleine Wehwischen, aber sie ist fit.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Geschwister.
Ist er oder sie gesund?
Sie sind beide gesund.
Okay, Herr Hans, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt.
Wann wurden Sie geboren?
15. Februar 1963.
Und wie viele Fragen haben Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 75 groß und wiege 85 kg.
86 kg.
Okay, Herr Hans, ich bin mit meiner Frage fertig.
Haben Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Wenn ich Schmerzen will, kann ich mich nicht sagen.
Okay, okay.
Sie geben sofort eine Schmerzmittel, Herr Hans.
Können Sie mir schon sagen, was ich habe?
Ja, Herr Hans, so seit leider kann ich eine Diagnose sagen.
Aber ich würde eine Körperleihuntersuchung durchführen.
Dann würde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Vielleicht würde ich eine Abdomen-Ultraschall durchführen.
Ich werde Ihren Fall mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Danach kann ich genau Diagnose sagen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Ich habe die Beschwerden seit der Nacht.
Ich habe die Schmerzen im Unterbauch.
Ist der Schmerz dauerhaft oder werden wir die Schmerzen?
Nein.
Sind die Schmerzen mit der Zeit verändert, verschlechtert oder verbessert?
Ich habe die Schmerzen nicht weg.
Sie haben die Stattung gesagt, kein Problem.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Was?
2 Mal in der Nacht.
Sie haben gesagt, kein Problem.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, in der Letzerzeit abzunehmen?
Ist auch gefragt worden.
Haben Sie eine Schwellung oder Vorwölbung im Unterbauch bemerkt?
Ich habe noch nie eine Koloskopie gehabt.
Aber der Petit hat gesagt, dass ich keine Schmerzen gehabt habe.
Aber auch im Rahmen der Vorsorge habe ich keine Koloskopie gehabt.
Mein Haustart habe ich darauf angesprochen, dass ich eine Koloskopie machen soll, weil ich schon über 50 Jahre alt bin.
Aber ich habe diese noch nicht wahrgenommen.
Was ist das?
Blutarmut.
Ich habe das alles seit der Nacht.
Seit ungefähr 9-10 Stunden.
Was bedeutet Prostat auf Deutsch?
Prostat drüze.
Haben Sie in Letzer Zeit etwas Ungewohntes gegessen?
Nein. Ich war auch nicht im Ausland.
Ich habe auch nicht schwergehoben.
Ich habe mich nicht überanstrengt.
Ich habe mich nicht überreicht.
Was ist das?
Ich habe einen Tennis.
Was bedeutet Tennis?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Tenesmus.
Das sind auch kampfartige Schmerzen.
Nein.
Beim Schutulgang fühlt der Patient nicht nur Schmerzen, sondern auch eine Küche.
Stuhl dran.
Schutul dran.
Okay.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie es für mich gesagt?
Ja.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberast.
Es handelt sich um Markus Hans.
Er ist ein sehr guter Patient.
Er wurde 5. Februar 1968 geboren.
Herr Hans stellte sich bei uns wegen dem Gestern.
Er stellte sich bei uns wegen dem Gestern.
Abdominal Schmerzen mit Schütteralung im linken Leisten vor.
Der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen zum ersten Mal sei.
Die Schmerzinterstate liegt bei 6-7 von SIN auf einer Schmerzkala.
Der Patient gab an, dass er 2 Mal Ibuprofen eingenommen habe, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Als Begleitseptom bei ihm war die Folgen dann aufgefallen.
Ich fieber 39 Cessius.
Er hat Verstoppungen nach Diary oder Melena Hermetames.
Er hat Neusea nicht verneint.
Er hat Übelkeit.
Die vegetative Anamnese war unaufwillig vor Insomnia wegen der Schmerzen.
Er hat 4 Monaten Hypotonie.
Er hat 5 mg morgens gegen Amnodipin.
Er wurde wegen von Konatros im linken Knie operiert.
Er wurde von 4 Jahren verneint.
Er ist unbekannt und er trinkt Wein pro Woche.
Er trinkt 1-2 Flaschen pro Woche.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er arbeitet als Brokkaufers.
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er ist am Myokardinfarktus.
Er ist gesund.
Er hat zwei Geschwister.
Er ist ein Anamnestischen, ein Angabendoytun.
Er ist ein Pepdik-Urkus.
Er ist ein Diagnostisch-Kommun.
Er ist ein Unterbauch.
Wo befindet sich der Pepdik-Urkus?
Bei der Pepdik-Urkus sind die meisten Epigastrikregionen.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Wo hat der Patient beschweren?
Unterbauch.
Wo? Rechts, links, mittig?
Unterbauch und links.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Welche Organe gibt es unterbauch und links?
Welche Organe gibt es da?
Es könnte sein.
Welche Organe.
Ebola, Berlinergath,
hier links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links, links
Libera, grandmother,
Was noch?
Er ist organisch.
Er ist auch organisch.
Gibt es den Daum dort?
Den Daum?
Daum?
Ja, links.
Gibt es keinen Daum?
Oder?
Ja, trans...
Nein.
Sigmoid?
Sigmoid Colon?
Ja, sehr gut.
Es hört sich gut an.
Okay.
Leiste gibt es auch noch.
Leiste in der Region, zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Aber hebbliches Ulkos, linker Unterbauch.
Schwierig, ganz schwierig.
Ja.
Okay.
Was heißt?
Welche Diagnose haben Sie?
Die Welt klitz.
Es könnte sein.
Ist denn eine Diagnose bekannt bei den Patienten?
Der Patient...
gab an, dass...
ihre Hausarzt...
vor...
elf Jahre...
hat...
die Diagnose...
jahre...
hat...
er...
ihm...
gesagt, er sollte...
Kolonoskopie...
durchführen.
Aber...
der Patient...
der Patient wurde nicht...
eine Kolonoskopie...
durchgewührt.
Also, er hat keine Kolonoskopie bekommen?
Ja, keine Koloskopie bekommen.
Ist eine Diaveticulose bekannt oder nicht?
Hm...
Die Welt klitz...
ich weiß nicht...
eine Diaveticulose bekannt.
Okay, wissen wir nicht.
Wir wissen nicht, ob eine Diaveticulose hat.
Ja.
Und...
äh...
Differenzielldiagnostisch...
hat Differenzielldiagnostisch...
kommen...
äh...
obstruktive...
Äh...
Darm...
äh...
die Diagnose...
Handraginfektion...
äh...
in Betracht.
Ja, ist okay.
Ja.
Welche Diagnose machen Sie jetzt,
bei den Patienten, um Ihre Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen?
Äh...
so als würde ich
Körperlihe
Untersuchung durchführen.
Mhm.
Und...
dann Labor-Untersuchung,
bei Labor-Untersuchung...
äh...
kleine... kleine Blutbild...
CRP...
äh...
und...
und Ihre Werte überprüfen.
Mhm.
Und dann...
äh...
Abdominale...
Ultrasound...
äh...
durchführen.
Und äh...
danach äh...
Was können Sie in Ultrasound sehen?
Oder was auch nicht sehen?
Warum machen Sie das Ultrasound?
Ja... äh...
Ich werde Ultrasound
durchführen
und äh...
äh...
nieren, nieren
Stein
äh...
und äh...
Obstruktion
äh...
Ausschließen.
Mhm.
Eine Obstruktion
auszuschließen.
Was meinen Sie mit Obstruktion?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Ja, äh... Obstruktion...
Von was?
Ist äh...
äh...
äh... die...
Kolon...
bei der... äh...
Diktar...
kann nicht... äh...
äh...
Studank... äh...
Studank führen
oder äh...
Was kann ich sagen?
Meinen Sie Ilius?
Ja, Ilius.
Ah, okay.
Ja.
Okay, was können Sie noch
sehen im Ultraschall?
Was können Sie noch?
Ja, was können Sie sehen?
Ja... äh...
Was können Sie sehen?
Bei der Ultraschall
äh...
kann...
können wir nicht
eine Dwarvenkulisse
sehen, aber...
Ja, äh...
aber ich kann
Hinweis auf die Dwarvenkulisse
sehen.
Aber äh...
Sie können sehen, ob die Darmwand
verdickt ist.
Ob eine freie Füssigkeit da ist.
Ja.
Sie können sehen,
äh...
ob...
ob ein Absäster ist, zum Beispiel.
Ob eine...
eine...
eine Raunforderung da ist,
können Sie sehen.
Ja.
Mit welcher Untersuchung
können Sie die Dwarvenkulisse
besser sehen?
Mit welcher Untersuchung?
Ja...
ich würde gerne
eine Colonoskopie
dürfen.
Richtig, aber er scheint
gerne Entzündung zu haben.
Würden Sie dann trotzdem
eine Colonoskopie
machen?
Wie bitte?
Wenn ein Patient eine akute Entzündung hat.
Er hat Fieber,
er hat Unterbauchschmerzen
und sagt, er hat auch ein
erhöhtes CHP.
Würden Sie trotzdem
eine Colonoskopie machen
oder eher nicht?
Ja...
so erst
werde ich
eine Kompetenzer-Tomographie
durchführen.
Ganz genau.
Da können Sie sehen, ob eine Entzündung da ist
oder nicht.
Und eine Colonoskopie zu machen
wenn eine Entzündung da ist.
Ja.
Wie würden Sie den Patienten
therapieren?
Ich würde...
Wenn das CHP
erhöht ist,
dann sind Sie erhöht.
Was würden Sie mit den Patienten
nach Hause schicken
oder straxone aufnehmen?
Ich würde der Patient
stationär aufnehmen
und
eine Flüssigkeit zu holen
und eine Pärtherapie
und
eine Oralnauerung
absetzen.
Sie sind nicht.
Ja.
Er kann weiter essen.
Er soll sogar weiter essen.
Okay.
Und Antibiotika-Therapie?
Was würden Sie ihm geben?
Welche Antibiotika?
Dritte
Generation
Sepolosporin
und
ja.
Noch was?
Noch was.
Metronidazol
oder warum?
Warum?
Ich meine,
meine, eine
Anerob,
Anerobbbakterie
in hier.
Und die auch abzudecken?
Ja.
Genau.
Okay. Würden Sie denn
eine Kurskopie empfehlen
später?
Natürlich. Auf jeden Fall
würde ich
Kolonoscopy vorschlagen.
Ja.
Aber erst später, nachdem
ihr in Zündung gehalten ist.
Ja, nach der Ernstüpfung, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es sonst Fragen, Anmerkungen?
Alles klar, ne?
Alles einfach.
Welche
Medikamente
schrieben?
Was meine ich?
Ja, man kann, wie immer,
wie gesagt, mit Rene
auf jeden Fall nehmen
bei einer komplizierten
Iveticulitis
und zusätzlich entweder Amoklav
oder man kann Ziprophoxazine
oder auch Zephyroxiven geben
bei einer
unkomplizierten Iveticulitis
kann man auch entweder nur
Amoklav geben
oder man kann auch sagen, okay,
er hat kein Fieber, kein
Entzündungszeichen, gar kein
Antibiotrien geben.
Abwarten.
Geht auch. Nur Schmerzmedikamente,
Neurominsulphon,
Renterliebe-Profen
und Zupfohre.
Und der Patient hat Obstipation?
Er hat schon immer Obstipation gehabt.
Das ist nicht neu.
Nicht neu?
Er hat das immer
für eine Obstipation.
Man kann natürlich geben Movicol,
Makrogol, kann man geben.
Man kann sagen, er soll
vielleicht flosamen Schalen essen.
Man kann empfehlen,
eventuell, wenn sehr stark Obstipation ist,
Lachsobaraltropfen zu geben,
oder auch zu machen.
Okay.
Unser Kollege
hat gefragt,
zusammen
mit der
Frau,
sie
hat eine andere
Antwort
gesagt.
Diese Fragen ist wichtig
in Deutschland.
Doch, doch.
Kann man stellen,
aber in der Regel leben verheiratete
Menschen zusammen.
Ja, deswegen
muss man nicht stellen.
Kann man stellen.
Wenn ich gesagt habe, ich habe eine Freundin,
dann kann man die Frage stellen.
Aber in der Regel leben verheiratete
Menschen zusammen.
Okay, danke schön.
Herr Kollege,
wie geht es Ihnen?
Bei dieser
Fall gibt es
ein Wort,
eine Wort Bauch
oder etwas,
zu führen?
Es lohnt sich nicht wirklich, es sei denn,
Sie haben den Verdacht, ob Akute
Saptomen,
wenn Sie den Verdacht haben,
ob Akute Saptomen,
dann kann man natürlich eine Wölkchen machen,
um Freiluft auszuschließen
oder auch ein Illus zu sehen.
Aber wenn Sie sowieso ein CT machen,
dann reicht das CT eigentlich aus.
Der Patent hat gesagt,
manchmal wenig, manchmal ist es okay.
Können wir sagen undulieren
oder wenn in Formik?
Wir sagen vielleicht undulieren,
das ist schwierig.
Aber undulieren vielleicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay.
Aber wenn in Formik geht auch,
ja,
weil der Darm schmerzt ja durch die
durch die
wenn in Formik kann auch wenn in Formik sein.
Schwierig.
Bei der FSP
hat der Patent gesagt,
ein bis zwei Gras Wein
müssen wir diese Fragen
aufklären.
Mit was?
Detailieren müssen wir ja, oder?
Also man kann
fragen, ob er auch mehr trinkt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Herr Issa
hat gesagt,
er wusste gar nicht,
wie viel er trinkt.
Er hat sich aufgeschrieben.
Er trinkt Wein in der Woche, hat er gesagt.
Wein in der Woche,
wie viel Wein?
Eine Flasche, zwei Flaschen,
einen Kasten Wein.
Man muss genau fragen am besten.
Man kann auch fragen, trinken Sie
auch mehr
trinken Sie auch außerhalb
Wein etwas.
Kann man auch fragen,
wenn man den Verdacht hat,
dass der Patient eventuell ein alkoholisches Problem hat.
Okay.
Der Patient hat FIBAR
und der hat auch
ein bisschen mehr
als der Patient hat FIBAR.
Aber wo gemessen
sind, ich weiß nicht,
müssen wir
fragen?
Kann man fragen.
Aber in der Regel ist es Ohr, meistens ist es Ohr.
Oder halt an der Stirn
mit den neuen Messgeräten,
kann man an der Stirn hier wissen.
Kann man fragen, natürlich.
Okay.
Eine rektale Messung wird nicht mehr gemacht.
Ja.
Aber es ist auch selber.
Haben Fragen, Kollegen?
Ich habe eine Anmerkung an
Herrn Isar.
Warum haben Sie am Ende erst gefragt,
wie alt der Patient ist?
Ja,
am Anfang
habe ich
vergessen.
Ja, deswegen
müssen wir am Anfang machen.
Ja, ja.
Das ist ja auch wichtig.
Die alte Patientin ist
90 Jahre alt,
20 Jahre alt, das wissen wir gar nicht.
Ja.